[Music]
do you know
why you come for me
[Music]
seeing as you demanding all now i got a
little deal i'm working on you feel me
how much how heavy
is he crazy like 110 grand like 150
i knew that if anything happened you
would let me work off the day you know
seven i hope you know what you are doing
you are taken away from me
i'll be out of the game before they even
know i'm on the court
competition in this business is not so
friendly
[Music]
it seems in our haste to do business
together we both did some very avoidable
mistakes
what have you been a snitch i'm not the
type of man you would be wise to
threaten
you have until tomorrow afternoon
my best friend set me up
you think they were gonna make it
no but we'll have fun trying
what now they all gotta go
all of them and then the future seems
pretty unimaginable
the past unbearable
[Applause]
[Music]
you almost went too far last time
you took away everything that i had left
how do you wanna die
dang baby that's pretty cool
[Music]
this is the kind of story where everyone
is to blame
and no one is spared
[Music]
[Applause]
then again they do say that love
conquers all
you